be a good muslim um don't let this
western philosophy
affect you uh know the truth know what
life is really about and
study islam just the only way to to turn
away from arrogance is to
learn never stop learning never stop uh
you know
moving forward yeah
[Music]
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm gonna start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith qut where he says that
the most beloved acts of worship to god
are those which he made obligatory
the person continues to get closer and
closer to allah key point gets closer
and closer
by voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
the three muslims podcast we're your
hosts ramified and angel
we are the realest podcast in the dhonia
and if you like what you see if you like
what
we are presenting today insha allah then
make sure you subscribe like and comment
and check out our patreon
today we're uh we are joined with a very
special guest allah
brother arya salaam allah how are you
doing
how are you doing today i'm very fine
thank you
so first and foremost i know you you
have some very particular
stances on on certain philosophies
western philosophies but first let me
ask
where do you live right now i'm
currently living in kurdistan so
kurdistan is a part of iraq
in reality it shouldn't be but because
of you know
britain after world war ii um you know
colonized us
and um split up kurdistan into four
parts
uh ali ali dawa is a kurdish part of the
turkish part like
kurdish in the turkish part uh i'm in uh
kurdish of the
iraq iraq party oh okay i've seen what
are the other two
uh in the iran and surya okay okay
so yeah do you so first and foremost
when it comes to colonialism and certain
places being you know colonized by the
west
um what are the negative impacts you
think that had on your people and people
around the uh
yeah people forgot forget their islam
like we are supposed to be a muslim
country like we have
muslim law and things like that but uh
because of this colonization
people have been oppressed and uh didn't
have their chances and
they look at their country and it's in a
bad place and they look at
for example the western world and you
see that it's so advanced so
this western philosophy has been like
literally imposed on us and
we are forgetting our ordin and we're
really focused on the dunya
and everyone is like everyone like this
this mentality that they have they have
to prove themselves uh that they're
worth it and
they they indulge in dunya they want to
focus on their work they
they forget the the deen like you think
they're muslim but they're not because
um like they're just uh muslim in the
outwards inside
they have the dunya in mind and uh you
know the western philosophy and
they forgot islam allah
subhanallah so if you could summarize
western philosophy how would you
summarize
it would you say it's like you know
trying to make as much money as possible
live the american dream what would you
say
like atheist atheism like with the
western philosophy in general
um they don't believe in the africa so
they want to
they think the purpose of life is to to
have the most enjoyment and happiness in
this life and
um their their stance on how they can
get this
happiness is very uh weird they think
that
if they indulge in for example in this
dunya they will be happy
so they they work a lot they um
drink alcohol like they listen to music
they
uh indulge in in a lot of dunya things
and like
for example like this is supposed to be
kudus supposed to be a
muslim country right but alcohol is very
prominent like
i know people like indulging it they're
addicted to it
and um you know it's very very
uh sad when i see like even this
affected me because
personally i'm born a muslim right but
i've been practicing
like for like a year now like i've been
getting into this for like a year now
but like
before this like all i thought about was
to prove myself like
uh yeah you know like i'm here like and
uh
like school is you know it's a way to
prove yourself so
uh all i focused on was like i have to
prove myself i have to work
really hard not to because i enjoyed not
for uh
yeah but like very focused on the dunya
so that you forget the akita that you
forget god and
i think this is something that is
happening uh the deen
islam is suppressed by the
western philosophy in here and
everyone's focused on the world
they're forgetting the dunya and um it's
mentally
in a people it puts people in a very bad
mental state yeah yeah subhanallah and
i mean it brings a lot of problems when
you when you factor in atheism right
because
that's one of the first things you
mentioned the fact that there a lot of
them are atheists
and if they're not hardcore atheists
they're secularists which means that
they divide
religion from you know their lifestyle
and their laws and their legislations
and all that
and this is so problematic for two
reasons subhanallah because one it's
saying
we accept the idea of god the
possibility that god exists in the
possibility of god's law
but we're not going to explore that
possibility even though it's the most
important question
to men um we're not going to explore
that we're not going to try and find
god's law we're going to make our own
extremely problematic for that from that
perspective for that reason
and the second problem that atheism
brings is the problem of
purpose why do you live why are you here
are you really just a bunch of atoms
floating around
um what is your consciousness is it
really your soul
you know do you have a soul and denying
the afterlife
is just one aspect of it um they're
denying
any you know objective purpose to this
life as well everything just a bunch of
atoms
floating around each other they think
everything
came about randomly like they don't see
the possibility of
a god creating everything they think
everything just came from
randomness but i have like i don't like
the the idea of randomness i
just don't think it's uh true i don't
think randomness
even a thing right i know i know what
you're talking about because for us the
hobby
was talking about um what is what is
randomness randomness is just our
inability
to to predict what's going to happen
right
um and he gave the example of someone
playing billiards right about to break
the um
the um the little setup and um
like he said that if you go to a
physicist and you ask him to calculate
um all like where all every ball is
going to land and everything
on the table if you tell him how hard
you're going to hit it you give them all
the factors he will tell you where every
single one is going to land
but to us it seems random right so if
you look at this like
for example like from god's point of
view even though we could never
understand
everything is calculated god knows
exactly what's going to happen and it's
not random
it's all calculated but we are just too
incompetent to know that
and um the second problem with with the
randomness
if it does exist is bismillah if it
doesn't slip my mind now
oh yeah the second problem is how does a
bun like for example if i were to tell
you that i spent my entire life doing
random things whatever part of my head
randomness i did it right you'd probably
assume i end up in jail or something
like that or dead
right like i'm on top of a building what
if i think of jumping off and i do it
right
or there's like an old lady in a grocery
store and i think i'm punching her face
and i do it right i'm going to be in
jail or i'm going to be
and that was angel's example from a
while back marshall love you guys
remember but um
i would be dead in jail or something
what if i told you i ended up being a
philosopher
and um an olympus and an astronaut and
all this stuff just doing random things
you'd be like there's no way in hell
right yeah another thing is like i
understand that like
the the definition of insanity is to do
the same thing and accept
expect the a different outcome like
randomness
imposes that if you do the same things
but randomness through randomness
like different outcomes happen but like
i don't think it just happens like if
you do the same thing the same way it's
gonna
come out the same way like the outcome
is gonna be the same way so randomness
i just don't see the possibility and
another thing is like how did like this
all of this thing suddenly became like
look at this like all of this light and
things like how how did
suddenly nothing became all of this like
yeah it just doesn't make any sense and
but people
don't think about it they don't uh
question the uh the western philosophy
this is another thing i want to talk
about like they don't question it they
they question islam but
and they think it's uh illogical to
believe in islam but it's not
logical to believe in like this western
philosophy like uh
you know things just came out randomness
or something like
it's it's so sad like to be honest with
you yeah
subhanallah it is it really is fine
what's up
yeah i was just thinking you all know
about entropy
yeah uh when yeah however everything
goes from
order to more disorder yeah so if you're
talking about
randomness or entropy then because dunya
wouldn't even exist
yeah everything went from disorder to
more order
yes yeah yeah it's also the problem with
um
evolution as well yeah you want to go
into a little bit more about
you don't need to name any specific
names but just people around you and how
their lives
um have changed due to this western
indoctrination and how you witness this
firsthand
here's the thing because all their focus
and their
their measurement of success is this
dunya
they get very caught up when something
bad happens uh there's a lot of
like um relatives i know uh something
bad happened to them they got a
they got a bad grade or um they don't
have money they have a lot of debt
um they don't like because they forgot
god like forg forget god
um what happens is that they're going
into very bad
rabbit hole like they're very depressed
and you know for example
they don't know that everything is you
know god gives
like you know what i mean it's not in
your hands but it but then you know
because of this western philosophy it's
like
you know everything is like um even like
self-help uh thing like you
you have the control over everything and
things like that um they get into a very
in a bad emotional state like i've seen
them like
and uh they forget like they might even
be
practicing muslim but because of this
western philosophy like it just
you could not have western philosophy
and islam at the same time you know just
one is going to take over and in this
instance uh the western philosophy is
taking over and
so it's it's very sad like they go in a
very bad state even i was like this like
i had to always prove
that i you know i i'm like you're worth
it you know i mean
you always uh for example like i don't
you don't have
that much success as like a 16 year old
right but then
i always got angry whenever they they
said like like
what do you have to report like i've
always wanted to prove myself but then
as i practice more and i know like wait
this is not life is not about that life
is not
about that it's just about worshiping
god and so i i kind of just
yeah you know detach myself from my ego
you know what i mean and
i don't expect people to praise me or
even criticize me i don't
need this anymore because like i'm
detached from them but because of the
western philosophy
um they're very detached like
their ego is like very egocentric like
if someone thinks of them
in a bad way they're they're hurt and if
someone is in a
think of of them in a good way they're
they're uplifted they're
um they're happy but but there's a
problem in this suit like they always
want praise from other people like
it's gonna be like drugs you know like
they're gonna get a little bit of
um you know um praise but then this is
not enough they need more and more and
more so they need to prove themselves
even more and more and more
so they can get more praise and praise
you know and
this is sad yeah man subhanallah
everything you're saying right now
is just normal here all these things
that you're telling me that you're
shocked about entering your country
that's not normal here right so it's
like it's weird that
that you're even talking about these
things and to us if
if you know we're not woke or practicing
islam we don't even notice it
like people are out here you know going
to parties drinking doing dumb ish
just to prove themselves or you know
working 60 70 hours a week not saying
you shouldn't work but
they're just identifying with it you
know they're forgetting allah
they're forgetting that the money is
coming from allah yeah this is a problem
like
like this should not happen to a muslim
country like they're all muslim like
they have to have this mentality like um
they have to learn about islam like they
know islam and they
they practice and they they're uh
righteous like this western philosophy
should not be like an issue like
this should not be an issue like where
i'm like seeing people there they're all
like
in this in this like a very bad state
like
but because this western philosophy is
is everywhere it's very
spreading very very um everywhere like
uh very rapidly and
it's sad like like if you go back when i
see my
grandpa grandpa and things like that
islam was more
um here like these were not problems but
then
i see like even um in the social media
and things like that people are trying
to
prove themselves and like um it's very
uh
you know for me when when you say like a
muslim country
i i don't i don't think this should
happen but like it's
spreading like uh this is a an issue we
should discuss like
why is this worse than philosophy it's
like spreading ever it shouldn't happen
like in my opinion
yeah have you have you ever seen this
video of uh of the
nigerian president talking to the bbc
reporter or cnn yeah
about she was uh she was she was
basically telling him like uh
you know why you know are you guys
homophobic why do you guys not want
uh you know to you know promote
homosexuality in all that new country
right
and you got the guy just saying we don't
want that in our country you know it's
not
it's not the fact that we're against it
or we're not against it it's the fact
that it's not our way
and we don't want to you know impose
this western thing and you know what she
said
she looked at him and she's like gonna
get in a lot of trouble for saying that
like bro who are you bro and then like
the most liked comment
on that video was uh some some like
western guy too
and he was writing like the west needs
to stop imposing their philosophy
into their system so i was gonna ask you
my question um
has there any has there been any changes
in the school system and what they're
pushing so you know
i learned like i can't even got into
more islam
uh because we have uh just like a
subject uh for
religion and the real religion we learn
is islam and it's so
weird like uh like it's it feels like a
football and you know the teacher comes
in
and just talks about it and you know i
kind of just like
kind of when my teacher spoke in the
class
you know i kind of you know my iman kind
of in
here's the thing i've always believed in
god you know my fitrah have been
like very good you know my my dad my mom
taught me like uh that god is exists and
things like that but i was not
practicing but
uh when this happened uh um
so i became more muslim but here's the
thing um we don't have
uh this western philosophy imposed on us
in this way
but more so on um through the media
through the media
it's impossible and um through social
media not
in school i i don't think uh you know
it's a school system in
kurdistan is not that good to be honest
with you like um
like we're not even studying like
i i passed half of my school just
randomly not randomly
randomly randomly yeah skip like
because we even had like the isis war
and things like that um
the the you know the education mystery
ministry
um kind of like said uh you know if you
have passed
the first semester you you you passed
the whole year and
so like my sister like literally uh
like have not studied as much as like a
first grader in
in america like so yeah the education
system is not really that good in
kurdistan
so yeah
but these problems are still here like
through the social media
and through um you know uh you know
social media and um
tv channels like this has been
impossible uh imposed on us
yeah what are they imposing
world like the worldly life things um
especially uh music
music is uh there's there's a song uh by
this uh kurdish uh singer it just says
baida which means uh just shake it like
like you're interested in the whole song
is about
you know why are they like limiting you
like you should you're free like you
should do everything like
uh through through media through uh
social media through
songs and like this is a muslim front
right but
music is everywhere like literally
i know what's on your mind well first
off man
for a 16 year old this is a
it's pretty amazing at 16 years old i
was a giant
so uh you have my respect for that
but it's just crazy like you're saying
all these things and
i it really it's i'm not trying to like
bring it i'm not trying to like make it
less
of what you're saying but it really is
like something that
it's just like we see it on a day-to-day
basis
over here in the west like i've seen it
since i was a little kid brother like
there was music there was all this stuff
being portrayed since the beginning like
over here that
there really is no talk about god and if
there is it's about jesus christ being
god which is
stuff for that's not right but um
i don't know man i guess it is pretty
crazy now that it's getting over there
to the muslim country like you wouldn't
think it would be over there yeah
mike is like
the problem is like we have a lot of um
messages like
um you know mosques and whatnot uh but
the problem is with imams like they
don't teach us they don't teach us like
i'm not like you i was uh i learned to
pray when i was 15. like
this is uh really bad to be living a
muslim country born muslim but not know
how to pray till you're 15. you know i
wish like um
you know they taught us more like it not
just like hide away the western
philosophy but like
show the truth like why the western
philosophy is not
what it is and like why is islam the
truth like
they don't teach us this like it's
brushed like it has
if you're uh if you're like a little bit
religious and you have like a little
beard in
um you have your uh your pants uh
above your ankle they make fun of you
like they say oh he's
suddenly and it's very sad to
uh to want to like practice your uh
religion but then in a muslim country
but
you know but they must make fun of you
you know
i don't think it should happen like but
here's the thing there's a cure for this
and it's just to teach teach and here's
the thing i i kind of
you know it's like arrogance it's
because of arrogance and if you teach
if you learn this you know this
arrogance is going to go away and
hopefully like um this is gonna happen
like
uh more teens are going to learn about
islam and all of a second
you know for the next generation like
this arrogance is going to be
less decreased
one thing let me know if this is uh
influ infiltrating in uh in the
kurdistan it's gonna be a quick question
bro so
angel can go in right after he's got a
question
you know you know there's this western
idea that
you can't marry young or you shouldn't
be married you shouldn't
tie down young you should wait till you
know you're done living your life blah
blah blah till you're 30
40 even whatever you got single people
till 50
but here people have you know girlfriend
boyfriend they're dating from 12 13. bro
i know 10 year olds that have
girlfriends so it's like bro people want
you know to
have a partner i'm not saying you know
every 10 year old should
you know do they do but i'm saying it's
going to happen here anyway because
they're gonna go dating and whatever
so i don't get this this whole taboo in
the west of our marriage
when people are gonna be dating from 12
13 in middle school
so is this weird backwards concept
in in the east now so it's it's
developing so here's the thing
one generation before my mom and dad
uh so my mom was 18 when she married and
my dad was 21 but now my mom is telling
me and my sister
to marry each other like we're 30 to see
the world and what not you know and
this is not like this is not something
we we learn in islam is this
totally something from the western world
but then it's you know it's
i don't know how this happened like it
affected my mom
and that now it's like it's kind of
coming on to us
like but but i don't believe in that
like like
mary in a young age should not be a
problem but then you know
it's kind of like it's kind of
developing like this idea
and uh more and more people like even um
for example my
uh uncle kind of married when he was
like 26 or something like
very late in his his life like it's kind
of like developing it's kind of
like uh i hope we can stop this right
now because
if we don't it's going to be we're going
to be worse than uh
you know american western royalty
i don't want this to happen to like a
muslim country because this is a muslim
country
why is this happening
making me feel old bro i'm 27 i'm not
married
no no it's okay in
in america but like yeah i know what you
mean but i know
uh but question for you man why do you
think he's getting to that point
oh arrogance like like and another thing
it's like
we see isis like padre in a like jersey
isis has nothing to do with islam but
then the media like give
so much power to isis be like oh it's
some muslim force but it's not
and and people are staying from istanbul
because of they see the shiny new object
it's
western philosophy they're seeing uh how
uh you know through the internet they
see they see
um like everyone like in america how
they're living and
how open they are and what not and they
think they're so uh
they're happy and like they're steering
from islam
and you know they're moving toward
this western philosophy and it it's so
sad like another thing is
like arrogance as i said uh they're
steering from islam and
going through the western philosophies
and another thing is like
muslims are being portrayed as bad and
this is like
it's so important to to be a good muslim
because
if you're not people are going to see
islam is a bad way as a backward
way right and especially uh like
if you do if you're not a good muslim
you're gonna be like
you know is that islam and they're gonna
move away they're gonna
turn off be turned off uh by this idea
and they're gonna search for alternative
and western philosophy is everywhere
and so it's kind of like it's just it's
like
they just go there so
it's very important to be a good muslim
yeah man there's even muslims in the
west here
imposing this like sugar uh you know
more
liberalized westernized version of islam
because they're afraid that if we tell
her
you know two sentence speaker truth that
we're gonna be deemed
extremists and we're gonna be deemed
like you know this is so backwards or so
you know difference from status quo
and it's a shame because you know all
these you know reformers or
um you know people that that try to
change islam and try to like you know
nullify it
it's people are losing the message of
islam like i have i have literally
people like
tweeting stuff like oh just because i
don't pray just because i don't drink
just because i don't believe in allah it
doesn't mean i'm not a muslim
bro why what makes no sense
i don't know but man
uh yeah if there's anything else man
that'll be known
yeah be a good muslim um you know
um don't let this western philosophy
at hindu like affect you
know the truth know what life is really
about and study islam
you know uh you know just the only way
to
to turn away from arrogance is to learn
and
it's very important and never stop
learning never stop uh
you know moving forward yeah inshallah
i want everyone on today in the comment
section if you made it this far
uh write down hashtag bring back arya
because we need brother arya again
part two but also when you guys uh make
some you know salad today make some
special uh duel for brother arya
for continuing to speak his truth in
this time of chaos
and inshallah you have a bigger platform
one day to uh get this message across
and you continue
uh you know telling people the truth
because the truth is enemies and today
you are different than those around you
today even though you
are following the straight path so don't
let that ever change you bro
thank you yeah and keep keep doing your
thing brother because
at 16 like i said man mashaallah
thank you
i mean all right subhanallah with that
being said
all right god is back with that being
said may allah bless you all and let
this be a lesson to ourselves and to
yourselves
um don't fall for it to wake up to it go
back with them go back to allah
today at the end of your life you will
be brought back to your lord and you
will be held accountable for what you
did
and you will not be able to blame anyone
else with that
a lot of people have this misconception
that you know once i feel closer to god
then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah key point gets closer
and closer
by voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
you want allah to love you do what allah
prescribes for you which is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
love will inshallah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
uh